hey guys i'm ryan right dan you go next
I'll go next
I'm Dan Seibert I'm Dave douchebag Dave
douchebag over David Stoddard some of
you guys don't recognize him as he is
the first subscriber we're having on the
channel we made it he made it here meet
again yes some journey there's important
people here a create a round of applause
it persevered walls trying to whatever
he was in California where you from
urgently I'm from a lot of places man
wow what wow give me birth she was
traveling the country I was born in the
Philippines you're born in the village
born enough nice now as you guys know
I'm half Filipino so and I'm the wife's
guy on the couch yeah I get I got like
mixes of like part black part part Irish
oh wow part German so you're like design
to kill design train to kill in turn
again and train that's really cool man
this is cool
first this guy ever to have I feel
special I feel special too
I feel extremely special yeah and Dan uh
you know he was in our Witcher 3 he's a
youtuber as well he's got his own game
review channel so and I figured what
better brosef type of bonding than to
watch a game trailer together huh hi
guys
yeah I'm sorry game Dan games games for
days games for centuries games what
that's impossible you know it's good
he created petitions by the way the
Salian ryan ryan right to be on Conan
O'Brien think about a good 230 now too -
yeah 770 more to go you got a sign-in
man but Ryan Wright and Conan on a
freaking episode of Conan
that was the funniest episode he would
make your day your mind would be blown
you mind what people on
things would be blown - for some reason
I don't know how that applies but it
does blow jobs what we're trying to get
out of here alright guys so we're gonna
watch the trailer today for this people
are talking a lot about this Middle
Earth shadow of Mordor cinematic trailer
I hear it's inspired by Lord of the
Rings sorry guy make sure some accounts
and other sounds like it must be Lord of
the ranges it is most likely Lord of the
Rings most it's about 99.99% little
ingredients they contain content
inappropriate for children like kids
oh wow oh that's pretty impressive
well it looks just like the movie is oh
[ __ ] son ah she's really upset about
that mark the mark is bad what the [ __ ]
you know oh yeah she's a [ __ ] bad
you guys wanna breath oh oh oh oh [ __ ]
this is how you play ass yes no way yes
you do awesome dude you're [ __ ]
Oh
nice Oh
I'm assuming things went well he's got
good aim I guess shadow Mordor dude
that's cool is that based on actual or
the Rings characters I totally made up
its have no idea it's not different
because I've read up a little bit I
started following a little bit once I
saw the first trailer of this thing
basically you're a human that has like
the ring wraiths rats rates powers cool
or so you're like commune with them and
you can like enter you know when Frodo
puts the ring on and he goes into like
that weird dimension yeah that's
basically your ability is to like
control that dimension and be in that
oh sweet ass dude cuz you're stoddard
any thoughts I want to dominate as this
guy and just terrorize and Wow
and I want my eyes to glow like that I
like oh I can see you matter yeah you're
really buff it's kind of scary yeah you
buff with glowy eyes I don't think it
might be too much like have this really
nice presence but then you're like
really buff at the same time and it's
it's terrifying it's like the kind of
people you don't want to [ __ ]
correct yeah you did it yeah all right
cool umm very expressive eyebrows yet oh
it's it's gonna be a little prat it's
gonna be a badass game uh just based off
of like the stuff I've seen because that
mark on his face that's from you taking
over his mind oh you can [ __ ] take
over people's minds and then you get
like a target then everyone will get
like set up as like some like big like
rally thing and then you go and out and
all the guys you like took control of
suddenly start attacking all of their
friends so you see like the game footage
yeah I've seen some game photo John I
haven't seen this trailer yet
excited yeah there's a good like that
like the the game play play out like the
emotion in the mood that's really good
we did the the gameplay looks very much
like our Witcher camera Jerry saw it's
the gameplay and like the cinematics are
so close graphically it's oh wow wow
that's good cuz like I'm really
meticulous about motion capture and all
that stuff it looks it looks good you
guys know what pitch game I wasn't fit
in well with this group I don't just
know about movies I also know about
games I'm bald
mm-hmm I'm bald down they're related yep
good to know do my best sometimes it
hurts hey hey the ladies do grooming
yeah look the ladies do the grooming dig
the grooming no dig the grooming yeah
but what's coming into anyway guys yeah
if you're new to the channel click this
button up above de vie to subscribe says
subscribe please on it
yep it's so cool my little buddy's right
here my little buddy my little my little
buff buddies my homie right here and I
got buddy over here hmm
yeah Bobby yeah even though I knew only
very well yeah Bob Bobby's are the
subscriber cheese I'm the video right
now but I did want to say a special
thank you to Bobby for being here it's
be a disembodied voice for us you are
welcome
yes anyway guys it's that time of the
video have you all wait for work go
shouting out time Jen give shout out out
out this is all right now you see how it
now you're seeing the behind the scenes
about yeah I could see the way heavy
loads everything right there yeah yeah
so that's how you make the list yeah oh
yeah I didn't dan has a youtube Cal to
you click this button
I believe IDEO games this could be fun
he does game I play video games two
cameras about two - so Eddie this fast
okay okay
radar films 100 can I please get a
shout-out with a bunch of question marks
and exclamation marks well dude you've
just got one I didn't realize it but you
just got one by me saying your name like
that answer
yes yes shout-out to you
congratulations hope your mom is doing
okay
what a bang is mom Oh makes a ridiculous
amount okay I just want to make that
clear Dante Ramirez can you give me a
shout-out in your next video he asked us
a very very long time ago oh you shot on
your next video and say what state you
Dottie Ramirez California yeah that's
where I live man that's yeah don't they
Ramirez I want to fight about you man 50
cos it's Tony Vaughn said promise me
you'll do a reaction video for
Assassin's Creed and yo [ __ ] put in
thousands create unity when it's
cinematic trailer comes out at e3 as you
come out yet is it III know we are in
the safe zone my friend I will do a
reaction for you Tony Van Van Van Van
Van Van Van how do you finance it Tony
van
Tony van hey van over here man I Drive
the Red Pony van you like it yeah you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you I hope you're
ready for you free Tony van yeah you
better be ready better be ready you stop
coming for it and dance we had that
voice I would totally believe you
my dad absolutely you start I don't know
I'm pretty good
glad I our subscriber you cheese